now if you come this far in the video
and are wondering what's the point of
this can i just duplicate it up and up
and up and up and one yes absolutely you
can duplicate this file you can simply
highlight that all go command d
and
duplicate it up and up and up and up and
introduce more and more windows and do
a whole bunch of things to make this
exactly what you want but the purposes
of this video is very simple
if anything changes and i can guarantee
you from the first day you draw this to
the last day goes out on site
something is going to change every 10
minutes you don't want to have to go
into this project
and change the same thing 50 times if
you have repetition of floor plans you
want to create small modules or small
parts that can be quickly and easily
updated update it once save yourself so
much time so many headaches
if you're somebody that is in the
architecture industry or looking to
become an architect you're probably one
day dreaming of designing your very own
skyscraper well today i want to make it
so clear so easy that anybody who knows
even the basic understanding of archicad
can start to create their own skyscraper
okay so like always we're going to be
starting with the arcade select template
it is the australian 25 version for me
feel free to use whatever template you
have available to you guys the template
selection isn't too critical for what
we're showcasing today basically what
we're going to be starting with is by
creating the repetitive nature of the
skyscraper itself as you may or may not
be aware of most skyscrapers and any
other building really in general has a
fundamental planning policy that
basically dictates the shape the
structure the height and everything in
between so with any skyscraper it's
going to be extremely different that's
why none of them look exactly the same
besides creative flair of course so we
aren't really going to be focusing on
that base the base that basically
dictates the ground the social
interaction and the human element we're
just going to be focusing on the
repetitive nature of repetition of floor
plans so there's a couple things we want
to keep in mind when we start on the 25
select template one we want to make sure
that all our story settings are
identical throughout the project so that
means
any time that we do anything and start
creating new files new master layers and
new hot links we don't want to have any
of our levels different so let's start
by pressing ctrl and 7 to open up our
story settings what you'll see is we
have our ground first and our roof which
is a very very basic setup i always just
simply untick all of those on the side
because i don't care about them in
elevation but you can leave them ticked
if you want that's just personal
preference
now let's say we're starting with a very
big skyscraper we're going to insert
something below and we're going to call
it our footings footings on a skyscraper
are huge but the footings layer isn't
actually that important so we can
make it whatever height we want we can
make it 100 mil for a standard concrete
slab we can make it three meters for
mass concrete footings for those columns
that are going to be supporting this
structure
or we can leave it as absolutely
anything it's really not critical as
long as it is identical throughout every
single file moving up again it's all
about that repetition it doesn't matter
what these numbers are they're going to
be unique to your situation your
construction material and methods so
what i put in here isn't exactly
critical but feel free to follow along
step by step so on our ground floor
let's say we want three meter ceilings
and then we want our ground ceiling
space with skyscrapers obviously it's
important that we have a ceiling first
of all we'll probably have a suspended
concrete slab that might be about 250
millimeters thick if not more plus
another 300 350 ml for all your
mechanical ducts all your clearances
that have to go through
in a high rise depending how big it is
it might even be more it might be 500
because there's going to be a tremendous
amount of services running through that
ceiling space
so in our ceiling space what we're
actually going to do we're going to
change it on this side over here to 600
millimeters for example next we're going
to go to our second floor and we're
going to repeat this step basically all
the way until we get to our top okay so
what i've gone through is done is gone
up to six floors only because i really
got lazy and i couldn't be going up
bothered going up to 50 so we'll make it
a six floor high-rise apartment
i just couldn't bother typing that's
literally it you can go as high as you
want as low as you want it's completely
up to you and your project but in this
instance we're gonna stick to six floors
and we're gonna make sure that every
single floor has a three metre ceiling
so for example ground floor has three
meters second floor has three meters
third floor has three meters and so on
all the ceiling spaces are identical to
keep it very easy for us to manipulate
later on so let's go okay and start
setting up this project in itself now
let's say we want to showcase the slab
all the way up to the next ceiling line
so basically what we're going to be
doing is using that ground floor and
that ground ceiling or part of that
ground ceiling really to create our
actual structure so let's keep it really
really simple and let's say we're going
to be starting on our ground floor we're
completely dismissing the principles of
skyscraper activation and we're
literally just going for straight tower
repetition so if we start on our ground
floor plan let's go drop one floor down
by pressing command down and going to
our footings layer we'll open up our
slab and let's simply draw a 15 meter by
15 meter square now if you're new to
arcade and have no idea how i drew that
square the slab tool over here clicking
once dragging out pressing tab allows us
to change the dimensions typing in 15
000 pressing tab again and typing in 15
000 again
then pressing enter creates our 15 meter
by 15 meter square now i can simply go
there and delete that square because i
do not need it and go back to control up
so we can go to our floor above which is
our ground floor simply right clicking
on the footings layout let's go show as
trace so we can see
where our actual floor is now if we come
across to our wall tool
we can make sure our layer settings are
correct we can make sure our
uh reference line is correct and we can
go ahead and select our wall type in a
high rise building it'll most likely be
a curtain wall but not always not
necessarily it could still be a
traditional build if it's like
six stories eight stories something like
that but if you start going to 50 60
stories and creating a very proper
skyscraper
most likely it will be a curtain wall
but for the purposes of this we're not
going into curtain walls we're just
going to select our 90mm stud partition
and draw a big box around that
entire slab so coming into 3d we'll see
that our floor is way too low so let's
just open up those settings project zero
reference that to zero so it comes all
the way back up and sits nicely in line
with our floor plate next let's go back
into the ground floor plan and let's
open up a window we're gonna just make
very generic windows throughout the
whole space we're not really going to
focus on how it looks again it's not
about the design principles it's about
how we fundamentally create vertical
towers in arcade so let's go okay let's
use one typical window and we'll
introduce it into the space let's say we
want that window to drag all the way
across and if we go into 3d we'll see we
have a highlight window we want that to
be floor-to-ceiling glass so i'll drag
that to the bottom
extend that all the way to the top and
then i'll go into the settings just to
change a few things around because we
don't want just one giant pane of glass
that's that's a ridiculously expensive
pane of glass and never really going to
work
so we're just going to go through these
first of all i'm going to tick this box
and change all my lines to black i hate
orange windows i hate the standard
template that is that's a different
argument we're going to go through this
and basically change our
fundamental settings so we can actually
introduce a few different things so if
we click across to our sash options go
to a hv grid let's say we only want one
vertically and we probably want about
or let's say 10 going horizontally
the grid thickness needs to be a hundred
mil and a hundred mil thickness this is
commercial framing now you'll see we
have one very big panel of glass that
goes all the way
from wall to wall and and the next thing
i want to showcase is cornering so if we
open up this again come down to our
custom corner go custom corner on custom
corner on we are going to make them 90
degrees and we click ok so if we come
back to our ground floor scroll down
we'll see that that window has been
sliced at a 45 degree angle and then we
can go ahead hold alt
select that window so we replicate those
settings
drag and drop that window on the other
side then command d
line it up and introduce a corner window
so if i come back into my 3d we'll see
we have our corner all the way wrapping
around and it's just solid glass it
isn't anything from a wall point of view
now i'm gonna quickly repeat those steps
on the other two wall as well and there
we have it now we have one basically
super large big box that will be filled
with
officers warehouses whatever you want
whatever you need that's basically what
the function of the space inside our
rectangle is going to be
what you would actually do speaking from
experience is you would dictate where
your lift cores go where all your
services are going to go where your
stairs are going to go and then you're
going to also position all your ducts
line up your toilets as best as you can
make sure your columns line up as best
as you can introduce a grid system that
is a whole kettle of fish that we can
get into later down the track feel free
to leave a comment down below if that is
something that you're interested in and
i'll definitely make some sort of video
to basically run you through a lot more
in-depth architecture of skyscrapers
but more so this is again about
replicating floor plates up and up and
up over and over and over again so now
that we have the fundamental basics of
our shell we're just going to simply
press the command up button once more or
the control up button depending on what
kind of system you're on go to our slab
tool let's change this to ceilings and
introduce a 15 by 15 ceiling which if we
go command t we're going to change that
generic roof let's just make it 10 mil
and i'll override the surface it's just
some glossy white so we don't have to
worry too much about it it'll basically
introduce one box here now what i'll do
is click on that and simply drag all of
our corners in a hundred mil so the
ceiling actually sits on the inside of
the building not the outside now just a
quick little point before we get any
further into this video i want to make
sure that you guys are aware of the
links that are down below in the
description box
there are some phenomenal resources for
architects architecture students and
anybody in the industry basically down
below is a library of links that is
going to allow you to better yourself
and level up to the next level there is
a whole bunch of architectural resources
on my website for example there's a
construction drawing checklist that you
can go through and tick off one by one
everything that you need on the
construction set of drawings so you know
and are very comfortable that when it
leaves your desk it is done to the best
standard possible there's archicad title
blocks and a whole bunch of other things
as well
there is also a fantastic discord chat
linked down below that is ever growing
with some incredible people in there
everybody in there is almost more
experienced and more knowledgeable than
me which i'm so thankful of and so
grateful of that we can continue to
create a community where everybody is
able to help each other grow learn and
be better professionals so even if you
are a student if you're in for just
learning archicad or if you're anybody
in the industry make sure you join that
discord chat because it is genuinely
filled with some great people who are
always happy to help out and make sure
that we better ourselves each and every
day anyway enough of my rambling let's
turn back around now if you come this
far in the video and are wondering
what's the point of this can i just
duplicate it up and up and up and up and
one yes absolutely you can duplicate
this file you can simply highlight that
all go command z
and
duplicate it up and up and up and up and
introduce more and more windows and do
a whole bunch of things to make this
exactly what you want but the purposes
of this video is very simple
if anything changes and i can guarantee
you from the first day you draw this to
the last day goes out on site
something is going to change every 10
minutes
you don't want to have to go into this
project
and change the same thing 50 times if
you have repetition of floor plans you
want to create small modules or small
parts that can be quickly and easily
updated update it once save yourself so
much time so many headaches now
basically what we're going to do with
this is go back into our ceiling plan
press command down or control down
and select our marquee tool we are going
to use the all floors selection and
basically just marquee that whole
building
next what we want to do is go file save
as what we're going to do is we're going
to come down to our module file we're
not going to save it as a pln you can
save it as a plan and hotlink p lens in
but i find it a lot quicker from an
operating system point of view to hot
link modules again million other ways do
this i just find this relatively simple
and easy so what we're going to do is go
module file and save that to our desktop
and click ok now what we're going to do
is go file save as once more and save
that as an archicad pln to our desktop
so we have a base file to play with and
basically then we're just going to
reintroduce all those modules in to our
arcad system so let's go pln save and
continue working on this project
now that we've got this saved as one a
pln and two module file if we wanted to
change something in the module file we'd
simply open up that module in arcad
change it save it and update it and it
will do everything in this file itself
so before we introduce a new module you
want to create a hotlink layer that
basically is going to store all of the
information of the hot link on one layer
that masters and turns it all off so by
clicking ctrl l it opens up the layer
settings i go new zero zero space hot
link and okay so next we're gonna go up
to file we're gonna go to external
content and we're gonna go place hotlink
we're gonna select our module from where
we saved it so new module from file for
me it was simply on the desktop so we
select that skyscraper module one we
click ok we want to input all our
stories again remember that it's
important these stories are exactly the
same that's why i just simply saved this
file so i don't have to go back and
duplicate those stories click ok click
select
we are going to link it so it has a
hotlink general file i'm going to go to
my zero zero hot link file just because
i wanted to show you guys really how to
create a hot link the master id none of
this is really important we want to keep
our elevations as in the story structure
of the hotlink source if something
changes we can then adjust elevations to
story structure of host project
but for the time being literally all
those settings work perfectly for us and
we're just going to go place hotlink
it's going to take a few seconds and
then all you do is click ok
and click once again off the file if we
come into our 3d we're going to see that
we basically see exactly what we saw a
minute ago but if we press command l
again and open up our layer setting we
can then turn on our hotlink file go ok
and you'll see it's doubled up on our
environment so
if i try and find our master hot linked
layout which is completely grouped and
basically free to move as i see fit we
can then press command z and begin
lifting that up like we originally
intended to and then command d again and
simply
dragging it up all the way as far as we
need to our top floor
so there now we have six stories of
identical tower
done so quickly so seamlessly so easily
that we don't have to worry about doing
any other changes and as you can see
moving around spinning it super quickly
my computer still functions
100 okay it doesn't slow it down it
doesn't lag it giving the model and this
it shouldn't lag whatsoever but
fundamentally speaking when the project
size increases it doesn't lag so much as
if you were to design it all in one
master file for example an argument's
sake let's go file open open and let's
open our module file that we saved
before i'm going to launch a new
instance of archicad and change
something up here so let this load i'm
going to completely mess with the ground
floor plan and show you how quick and
how easy it is to basically change
everything at once and with a snap of
two fingers
it changes everything vertically for you
no problems whatsoever okay so my module
file is now open over here and let's say
we've we've done some cool things we
want to change the shape of this
building entirely it's no longer what we
thought it was going to be so let's mess
with it a little bit let's have some fun
let's start by deleting that wall
entirely replicating that wall system
over here creating some sort of entry
cut into the building
jutting back at 45 and clicking okay if
we come back into our 3d we'll see
very different building very very
quickly we're going to do the same thing
on the opposite side of this building
we're just going to basically introduce
some sort of interesting characters some
sort of interesting elements to make
this building stand out and not look
like a boring box now i'm going to go up
to my ceiling plan right click on my
ground floor plan show us trace by
holding the space bar i'm going to cut
everything out that i don't want again
repeating those steps cutting out the
building areas that i don't need and
last but not least i'll come down to my
slab and do that exact same step so
holding a space bar clicking into shapes
i don't want cuts it all out all gone
there we go now we have two facades at
the moment that our solid glass and a
bunch of sides that are concrete we can
leave it as that for argument's sake or
we can introduce some more glass to make
it one solid skyscraper i'm quickly
going to go in in fill this with glass
and then come back to this 3d window so
you don't have to watch me replicate
glass for 20 minutes so i've completed
one side of the project entirely out of
glass and the rear side i've left is
concrete simply just to create something
different in the project and literally
it is very very simple from here on in
now what we have to do is we got to come
back in marquee that again
go file
save as scroll down to module file and
replace our module by pressing ok
now to update the master file all we
have to do is come into file external
content hot link module manager we find
our module that we've hot linked let's
quickly go re-link from file just to
repeat the simple steps find the module
click ok
go okay and press done now it's going to
update everything letting it do its
thing pressing ok
we are going to see
a dramatic change in the building now as
you can see this was part of the
original hot link
manufacturing process so we're simply
going to delete that
right click on our module above and
duplicate that to our ground floor so it
repeats all the way around
and there we have it that's literally
how easy and how quick was that to
replicate and change six stories in a
matter of seconds
it is so much easier than having to go
through and literally change every
single thing multiple multiple times
over you can do this with bedrooms you
can do this with bathroom designs you
can do this with whole floor plates if
you want to if you're confident enough
you can do it with lift cause you can
literally do it with whatever you want
because the fundamentals of this are
exactly the same throughout anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching i hope you enjoy
the tutorial i hope you learned
something very valuable today that
you'll take with you into your careers
and hopefully one day design your very
own skyscraper if you did make sure you
smash that subscribe button down below
and don't forget about the like button
believe it or not that like button the
little tiny little like button that
turns blue if you hit it helps this
channel so much with the youtube
algorithm i can't stress it enough
seriously the like button genuinely
helps this channel grow it helps more
people see these videos and it makes
sure i keep making these videos for you
guys but that is all for me today like
always i'll see you next monday